Hello.
So some of you may have heard about the
Google memo at his been circulating
virally around the Internet for the last
couple of days.
That was written by James Damore who was
fired for it last night.
And a colleague of his reached out to me
and put us together.
And so I'm going to talk to James today
about exactly what happened and why and
perhaps what should be done about it.
So all,
so that's what we're going to do in the
interview I had with him,
which finished at about three o'clock on
Tuesday,
August 8th follows immediately after
this introduction.
Hi everybody.
I'm speaking today with James Demore and
an unidentified google employee who
wishes to remain anonymous.
Um,
reasons that I think are obvious.
And James last week put his hand in a
blender by circulating an internal memo
that I would say has become somewhat
infamous.
So James,
let's start with,
let's start with a bit of discussion
about you to tell us who you are,
about your background,
and about what you were doing at Google.
Yeah.
So I,
I was actually just,
you know,
I'm really interested in science and
psychology and stuff and then I really
like puzzles and that's how I got into
Google.
Actually.
I did one of their coding competitions.
They just recruited me out of that.
And so I Google,
I was mostly working on search and image
and video search in particular.
So what's,
tell us about your educational
background a bit.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I just did a random science and math
and undergrad and I ended up with a
degree.
I didn't really know what I was going to
do.
So I started doing research at Mit and
then,
uh,
I went to a systems biology at Harvard.
I initially wanted to work with Martin
Nowak.
He's really great at and evolution and
Game Theory.
But,
uh,
then I started working on other things.
Okay.
So tell us a bit about systems biology.
What is that exactly?
What kind of research were you doing at
Mit?
Yeah,
so it sounds,
biology has many different meanings,
but it's generally just mathematical
biology and uh,
I guess seeing biological systems as a
whole rather than just individual
molecules.
And so I,
I liked looking at populations and so my
interest in evolution.
So why did that make you a viable
candidate and doodle?
It's eight.
Uh,
I think they just
saw a smart guy that could code.
Now you've been there three years,
is that correct?
But also has an intern before that.
Yeah.
So about four years total.
And so how would you say you've
performed as an employee and doable and
people being happy with you?
Or have you been here?
No,
I got promoted twice.
My last review was the highest possible.
Superb,
which is the top few percent aisle.
So I,
it definitely wasn't based on
performance that they fired me.
Have you enjoyed working at Google?
Has it been a good experience?
Yeah,
I mean I love Google then.
That's horrible part.
Like I've always been the biggest google
fanboy,
all like,
I've never had an iphone.
I've always tried to convince my friends
to use android and all of these
different things.
And yeah,
I mean this is just puts a sour taste in
my mouth.
Okay.
So,
so you've got a good educational
background.
You were interested in things that
Google would be interested in.
You're a good coder,
you've worked with them for a number of
years.
We've done an excellent job and you're
pretty pro google.
That's basically the background.
Okay.
Now last week you wrote a memo which has
attracted a tremendous amount of
attention and in that memo you,
you made a number of claims and the
claims were,
and please correct me if I've got this,
if I'm not summarizing this properties,
you were attempting to describe reasons
why there might,
why a lack of gender parity might exist
within Google for example with an NGO in
engineering or broadly but also in
patients more broadly.
And um,
you laid out in a very elaborated
document and I reviewed it and as far as
I can tell,
your opinions are well supported by the
relevant psychological science.
And I think what I'll do in the
description of this video when I link it
is putting the references so that people
can decide for themselves.
I want to put up a web page about gender
differences in general,
but I'll try to hit the highlights for
this particular document.
So why did you do this?
Yeah,
so about a month and a half ago,
I went to one of our diversity summits,
all of it unrecorded and to proceed
credit.
And they told me a lot of things that I
thought just were not right.
Okay.
What do you mean unrecorded in super
secret?
Okay.
Well,
I mean they were telling us about a lot
of these potentially illegal practices
that they've been doing to try to
increase diversity.
And
what kind of practices?
Uh,
well basically treating people
differently based on what their race or
gender ours.
Yeah.
Basically.
I
see.
And so,
and it was ultra secret,
an unrecorded.
And in what manner?
Uh,
yeah,
so I,
most meetings I Google,
I recorded anyone at Google come watch
it.
We're trying to be really open about
everything except for this.
They don't want any paper trail for any
of these things.
Okay.
Why?
Because I think it's illegal and I mean,
as some of the internal polls showed,
there were a large percent of people
that agreed with me on the document.
And so if everyone got to see this
stuff,
then they would really bringing up some
criticism.
Yeah.
A large number of people in Google and a
very large number of well-informed
biological scientists we might also add.
So I mean it was quite,
I was quite struck by your document
given that no,
it would have been a decent document for
a well informed psychologist,
research psychologists to write,
but it was somewhat of an outsider.
But you've got the,
you got the highlights accurate as far
as I'm concerned.
So,
okay.
So you went to this diversity meeting
and you weren't happy with the sorts of
things that you were being told and with
the practices is,
is that both correct?
Yeah.
And what were you mean tool?
Uh,
well,
so that
I think there's a lot of ways in which
they pressure people to increase the
diversity of their team.
And you know,
there's no way to do that besides
actually choosing someone based on their
race or gender.
Right.
I don't lucidity precisely,
uh,
I more women or underrepresented racial
minorities.
Can I jump in?
Yeah.
I would hesitate to say that that's 100%
true across 100%.
Right.
So the organization that I'm in,
I have not personally seen anything that
I would deem crossed the line.
Um,
you know,
I personally believe that there are a
good amount of synergies to be found if
you can combine,
you know,
slightly different ideologies,
um,
into a room.
And that is the,
the thesis that some groups are working
towards.
Um,
obviously there's going to be a
distribution of how people follow the
rules.
Um,
and you know,
it's unfortunate to hear that it's,
you know,
it could be that some people fall to the
wrong side of that distribution,
but that's certainly wouldn't,
it would not apply to everybody.
It certainly also distressing to hear
that there is acceptance of the idea
that diversity can be mapped on to race
and gender,
especially with regards to performance
because there's no evidence for that
whatsoever.
So.
Okay.
So you went to this meeting and then
you,
you just started to write this document
and,
um,
how long had you been working on it
before he released it?
Uh,
yeah.
So I was doing it like throughout my
free time.
I,
and I just wanted to clarify my thoughts
on this and I really just want it to be
proven wrong because you know,
if what I was saying was right,
then something bad is happening.
And so yeah,
about a month ago I submitted it to
feedback to that program and you know,
I saw that people looked at it,
but no one actually said anything.
And what's your,
and then did you submit,
uh,
I basically said what I said in the,
in the document and then I linked to the
document itself.
And so I actually published this about a
month ago and it was only after it got
viral and then we,
to the news that Google started caring.
Can you,
so how did it go viral and do you know
and how was it leaked?
Yeah,
so I,
there was a group at Google called
skeptics and so I was like,
okay,
maybe there'll be able to prove me wrong
in some way.
Like there's Scott's a rule about
things,
right?
I wasn't naive,
I guess.
And so I sent them a message like,
okay,
what do you think about this?
Is Google in some sort of echo chamber
or I'm crying and echo chamber.
And
then it just exploded after that.
And you know,
our internal,
yeah.
It was just spread throughout.
I've all of Google.
Do you and do you know,
was it the,
was it the skeptic's group that started
to spread it around?
Yeah.
And then there were a lot of upper
management that uh,
you know,
specifically called it out and start
saying how harmful it is and how is
unacceptable.
This sort of viewpoint is not allowed at
Google.
Yeah.
What sort of viewpoint,
exactly.
The idea that there were differences
between men and women that actually
might play a role in,
in,
in the,
in the corporate world that that's an
opinion that's not acceptable.
Yeah,
it seems,
well,
I know,
you know,
understandably it is,
these issues are tricky morally and
politically,
but thing that was disturbing to me
about watching the response to you is
that as far as I can tell,
there isn't anything that you said in
that paper.
First of all,
that is in fact biased in a manner that
should open you up to the sorts of
charges that had been opened up against
you or that violates the scientific
literature as it currently stands.
So both of those are rather distressing.
Yeah.
And there was a lot of misrepresentation
by upper management just to silence may
I think?
Yes.
And why is that do you think?
Like why?
Why is it the Google couldn't have
actually,
do you think that Google couldn't have
come out and have an intelligent
discussion about this instead of,
well,
first of all,
releasing like Dan,
I Read Danielle Brown's response to you,
which I thought was absolutely
appalling,
down to appalling.
And then they fired you,
which seems to be like really bad pr
move,
but more importantly,
it doesn't actually deal with the issues
at hand.
You know,
they're basically saying something like,
well,
what was the rationale for firing you?
Exactly.
What was the excuse that was given?
So the official excuse was that I was
perpetuating gender stereotypes
that you were perpetuating gender
stereotypes.
Yeah.
And it,
did they say anything else about your
performance or about anything else that
you had done?
Okay.
No,
it was,
that was the only reason.
And who,
who,
who fired you?
Technically?
Uh,
it was my hr representative and my
director.
Okay.
And do you end,
do you have any idea on who's ordered as
they were acting or if this was
something that they conjured up
themselves or,
hi,
I'm sure I probably went from higher up
than that because I'm,
this is a huge pr move.
So they would need approval from higher
ups.
Right.
And I think the CEO,
the CEO,
actually made some comments about the
issue today,
which I'll probably cut into this video
as we,
as I edited.
So,
yeah.
Okay.
All right.
So the first question is,
how are you doing?
I'm doing okay.
I,
there's a lot of messages that I'm
trying to sort through and just trying
to figure out what I should do now.
But
yeah,
you've been given some interesting job
offers as far as I can tell.
Yeah,
I've gotten a surprising amount as a
part.
Yeah.
Well,
I suspect I'm sacked.
I'm virtually certain that you have a
majority viewpoint.
It's just at the people who hold the
alternative perspective,
which are the radical social
constructionist types who insist that
everything is a consequence of
socialization.
There are a little bit more organized
politically,
but there are clearly wrong,
scientifically they're wrong.
So actually the wrong ethically for
that.
So,
so you,
you probably have more support than you
sake and it'll be very interesting to
see how that turns out.
So,
so what do you think about having
written this are mean now your life is
going to be turned upside down and for
quite a while I suspect.
So you put yourself out on the line
doing this.
So what do you think about that?
It definitely sucks,
but I mean at least I was proven right.
You know,
when,
what do you mean by proven right?
Oh,
just that the whole culture just tries
to silence.
I need a dissenting view
and then we really need some more
objective way of looking at these.
Yeah,
well I felt the same way with the
University of Toronto decided to,
you know,
an attempt to shut me down after I need
my videos.
I thought,
well that just proves my point.
Yeah.
Cause I mean to me the video saying well
I don't like the climate that's
developing and it's making it very
difficult to have conversations about
certain things.
And your examples even more egregious I
think because you know,
I at least objected to a piece of
legislation that in principle would have
been a benefit to an identifiable group.
But say the transgender group,
I don't believe it is of any benefit to
them,
but you could make a case that it was,
but you,
all you did as far as I can tell it is
review the modern personality literature
and the literature on individual
differences relating to men and women
and other groups.
And there's actually not very much
opinion in your piece at all.
So what that does is that it is not
possible to actually have a discussion
about the scientific literature on these
issues without putting yourself at risk.
And that's a hell of a thing for an
engineer because being engineers and
rely on the facts as far as I can tell,
and one of the things I liked about
engineers is that they tend to stick
fairly closely to the facts that they're
not a very political group.
You know?
Generally speaking,
they're much more practical.
Yeah.
I,
I don't know how that can expect a
silence so many engineers then
intelligent people and just
deny science.
Like it's like
this.
Yeah.
Well the question too is what are you
supporters within Google going to do?
Because you know,
I would say you're a great warning then
because you,
you showed what happened,
you showed exactly what happens if you
have enough,
I don't know what you'd call it,
curiosity and courage I suppose,
but,
but mostly curiosity to lay out what you
think for discussion.
I mean,
you opened this conversation,
you said that,
you know,
you weren't jumping up and down and
insisting you were right.
You were trying to lay out what you
understood from doing a fair bit of
reading and,
and make the case that the,
these facts,
the facts about the differences between
men and women and employment choice and
payment and all that aren't being
discussed and they're not being
discussed.
I mean we know for example,
and I'll put this citation in down in
the description that's been very
difficult for the,
the Swedes for example,
to flatten out the gender distribution
for engineers in Sweden and in and in
and in the Scandinavian countries in
general,
despite their advanced social
engineering,
let's call it.
And they also can't get male nurses.
You know,
I think it's four out of five nurses in
Scandinavia,
if I remember correctly,
are female.
And the reverse number are our engineers
are male.
And you know,
that seems to be associated with this
quite well founded.
Um,
scientific observation that women tilt
towards interest in people and men tilt
towards interest in things and that
that's associated with testosterone
exposure in utero.
This is so much science.
You know what?
It isn't anybody beating an ideological
trump because most of the people,
I would say that most of the people who
are publishing this would have been even
happier.
How did turn out the other way?
You know,
the findings actually run contrary to
their biases because academia is
generally full of people whose biases
are left and now and then,
you know,
scientific findings emerged to dispute,
um,
uh,
nydia logical proposition,
not certainly the case with the role of
biology versus society in establishing
gender differences.
So the science is very credible.
It doesn't mean it's completely beyond
dispute,
but that's not the point either because
your survey was actually pretty decent
survey of the current state of affairs
with regards to individual differences.
That doesn't mean it's right.
So,
okay,
so what,
what are your,
what does your family think about all of
this?
Yeah,
they definitely support me,
but they don't really know what I should
do from here.
They don't want me to just go to a ton
of news corporations and do all these
interviews and stuff and because they
just want a twist,
whatever I say towards their agenda to
it's,
it's not really clear what I should be
doing.
Yeah.
Well there's certainly no shortage of
people that want to talk to you.
I mean,
I'd been contacted by four or five
journalists who would like to speak with
you.
Um,
we can talk about that afterwards.
I could like to know who they are,
but um,
yeah.
Well,
you've got a,
you've got a conundrum on your hands.
Nope.
I mean you're,
you're a,
you're a very straightforward person and
you're obviously not grinding any acts,
at least not in any obvious way.
So my suspicions are that talking to the
right people could be of substantial use
to you.
But I guess it also depends on what it
is that you want me.
And that's something we can talk about.
Now you've,
you've,
you've rattled up the cages,
a fair number of people and a fairly
large organization.
Interestingly enough,
just on the heels of Google and Youtube
is announcement about the new free
speech restrictions on,
on Youtube,
you know,
when and their incorporation of NGOs
into that sensor set process.
So it's been quite a week for Google I
would say.
So you've opened up this can of worms.
What is it?
Yeah.
So imagine if you're looking six months
down the road and say,
and things happened that were good
because of what you did,
what is it that you would like to have
happen?
Huh.
I,
I at the very least I want,
because I do still care about google.
I want some conversation to be had and
for the ideologues to not just have
their way,
but yeah,
I still don't have a clear vision on how
exactly this will happen and how,
how this can spread farther than just
google.
You spread it farther than just google,
that's for sure.
Yeah.
You know?
Um,
I mean,
I would say my experiences with the
premise is that the first thing that
happens that will happen is that you'll
get jumped on by people who call you the
sorts of epithets that would be
appropriate if you were a bad guy and
you should just shut up and go away.